so how does a guy go about being
recruited to the kgb
uh unlike the cia where you can actually
apply
the kgb
you could not
uh they would recruit you they i
wouldn't have known whether where the
office was
uh they weren't in the phone book
and anyway i would never have thought of
applying
because you know from
you know i
like everybody else or like most people
you know spy spy stories are very
interesting we had our own spy stories
we had our own james bond
uh communist james bond
uh
so but that was all in the realm of
fiction or in the realm of adventure
that wouldn't be me i was going to be
a college professor that was my
that was my dream
but that changed one day when uh
the kgb knocked on the door
i was in my third year
studying chemistry
sitting in my dorm room on a saturday
doing a little bit of studying
and in those days um
the
almost all the students that could would
go home over the weekend i couldn't it
was too far
so i was alone in my room my roommate
wasn't there
and uh that's interesting to note
because the person who
knocked on the door knew this knew that
must have known it uh the person also
knew which room
under which behind which door to find me
there were no name plates on the door
so
after many years it occurred to me
i had i had a
neighbor in the next in the next
room there was a russian exchange
student
with whom i had some interactions and
talk back and forth i i guarantee you he
was the one who fingered me
why do you think why do you think they
chose you
i was as as you probably know in those
days the stasi had uh files on everybody
and uh
they
apparently gave access to those files to
the kgb or maybe they gave the kgb some
some hints that looked you want to talk
to this guy
if you systematically went through
files for students you know the
the future
intellectual elite of the communist
party the society and so forth
i was a standout he would shake this a
little bit and and my file would come
out for for two reasons
um
i was an active party member i was
active in the communist youth movement
of the university
but the the standout
entry was that i had just received the
uh karl marx scholarship
oh wow karl marx scholarship was
very rarely given
it was limited to 100 concurrent holders
in the country
100 concurrent in other words if you get
a new new one to go in somebody else has
to be out
and
[Music]
so
they were looking like the cia they're
looking for the best of the best and i i
was a good candidate on paper right
so
the fellow i got this knock on the door
and
we had a custom at
college at at the dorm
that you know
when you went to visit another student
in another room you knocked and you walk
in the knocking was just
telling them that somebody's coming
[Music]
after the knock the door didn't open so
i knew this would be a stranger
i'd say come on in and indeed it was a
stranger
the fellow
was
entirely unimpressive he was short
he had his right arm and in a cast
and he had he was just not likable he
was one of the few kgb guys that i
didn't like he was german
so right off the bat
i figured he was probably starzi
uh but when you say stasi what do you
what does that mean east german secret
police okay
stat seahawk that's an abbreviation for
security police okay okay
um
and then he came up
he he asked me
whether i am
i pressed at least that was my name i
said yes
what can i do for you
and then he came up with the
the dumbest statement i've ever heard
the kgb
agent uh
give
in my entire 10 years working with a
couple of dozen kgb agents he said
well you know i'm i'm from that from uh
called size yana there was a firm that
uh was very well known
uh in not not only in germany but in the
world that made uh high quality optical
instruments
and
then he said you know i just want to
find out do you have any what are your
plans after you graduate
now the reason it was dumb because in
those days
the entire time while east germany was
in existence when you graduate graduated
from college you didn't have the freedom
to choose
you were assigned so in other words
uh companies did not recruit never
happened
that guy didn't even know how his own
country worked
all right so when he said that i knew
immediately that's uh he's making it up
and he's probably secret police
now um
i wasn't
at all concerned that this would be bad
and it had to be something let's say
interesting
so
we talked a while you know i played
along with him
some you know small small talk
and you know what it's like to study
chemistry which
was
it was pretty hard because this is uh
one of the subjects where you have lab
so you spent
they want you to make plays every no
every afternoon after you have your
lessons and your seminars every
afternoon you spend four hours in the
lab then you have to write lab reports
and then you have self-study so my day
started at six
and it ended at ten
there was no play during the week
on saturday the morning
was lab
saturday afternoon that's when i went
for recreation and went to a soccer game
and
and then i went dancing trying to pick
up girls in the stone club i i usually
went home by myself
i was not as uh
as charming as i think i am now
too late uh and i was i was very shy
actually still anyway
so that that's what we were talking
about uh and
then he
abruptly uh abruptly changed his uh
his tune uh he did a 180 and he said you
know i gotta admit to you you know this
was just
a way to come in here you know i i made
that up i'm really working for the
government
i could have made him uh
uncomfortable by asking what part of the
government
i didn't want to do it you know i just
wanted to hear what he has to say
and
he he came right out with it he said
well can you uh
could you imagine one day to work for
the government
and i said
yeah
but not as a chemist
so do you think maybe they wanted you to
work as a chemist in the beginning like
maybe you make poisons and stuff like
that you know my my best friend from
college uh
actually did work uh for the stasi as a
chemist
he wound up uh the
as the head of the forgery department
and and he told me that uh the passports
west german passports he he forged he
they sold to the kgb
it is quite likely that he made a
passport that i used to travel with oh
wow
so yes
this is i think he really recruited me
uh because of what happened next he
recruited me for something not science
uh because he was he was a german who
was a volunteer
um collaborator with with the kgb wow
right i didn't know this when he said
government i thought it was the
secret police german secret police
so
the bottom line is he he had asked the
question he came to ask me for even
though not in so many words
and i answered him probably
exactly
gave him the answer that he wanted to
hear so he invited me for
um
to have a meal
when i say dinner it's
inaccurate it's all in germany the big
meal is at lunch time
so in in the most expensive restaurant
in uh
in in in town i still remember what i
had it was my favorite meal so but as i
walk in there he was already sitting
there in the back of the table and there
was another man at the table which made
me a little bit cautious because
in those days it was
not unusual for strangers to share table
tables because there were very often not
enough seats so i i just approached the
table uh slowly
but my man who never by the way gave me
his name not even a cover name
uh he came up to me and walked me to the
table and he said
uh i would like to introduce you to
herman
we are working with our soviet comrades
so it was clear that
it rhymes that's why i'm gonna say it
one two three i was with the kgb
i